Welcome back everyone. It's Charlie
This is going to be my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video the old man in the seat all about Rick's
Special special Zen plays I'm doing Easter Egg videos for all the episodes this season if you're new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get everything
We do a merge giveaway every week - I'll name a new winner at the end of this
Obviously careful for spoilers from the episode if you haven't seen it yet
We'll do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go along starting with number 10 meat glooty
Rick's new intern played by taiko YTD from thor ragnarok Fame
We open with the breakfast scene as he introduces glooty
the writer said that Rick
Basically wanted a slave somebody he could order to do all these menial tasks that he doesn't want to do anymore
normally
That would be Morty but because of the new family power
Dynamic in season 4 he can't ask Morty to do all that stuff anymore
So they introduced the concept that Rick totally knows about this dangerous app that glooty wants to develop because of his species
Wanting Earth's water and it being their secret takeover plan
But he's too lazy to tell them which Morty almost breaks the fourth wall when he references later in the episode
Rick was too lazy to tell us about this big plan that we should have avoided the writers
Also explained that glooty was created later in the process of making the episode
They created the high intern first played by Sam Neill
You probably recognized his voice
Also from thor ragnarok as the fake version of odin just a coincidence that he also happened to be in thor ragnarok with Taika Waititi
they created his character first and they needed a bunch of minions around him and glooty was one of those characters or the characters that
Became glooty
So then they turned him into a much bigger thing in cast ty kawauti deism
Rick breaks the fourth wall again when he says he's going on a solo adventure this time
This one not being directed by Ron Howard
Some of them gives away his secret that he's actually going to a special Oh ASA swear. He takes dumps by himself
They burn Ron Howard again when Jerry says he would be happy to have Ron Howard involved in his dumps
The writer of the episode Michael Waldron actually said that he based this storyline Rick going to the secret dumper based on his real-life
Experience in the Rick and Morty offices or at least in the old office that they used to have
Apparently a lot of the writers on staff have secret phobias of public toilets, but number 9 Rick's secret Zen planet of isolation
They actually called the planet Omega 2
It's just a special oasis of solitude very huge change from the normal chaos that you would find Rickon
So the writers the animators said everything about this
Planet was meant to show this other side of Rick that we'd never seen before and all this
Secret tech that he'd been working on that. We hadn't seen yet
But the title of the episode the old man in the seat is obviously a reference to Ernest
Hemingway's the old man in the sea
But in the context that this episode is meant to reference the special toilet that he has the episode itself is mostly about exploring Rick's
self-imposed isolation and then jeffrey wright
who was the other special guest actor playing tony gives him that big speech of the end where he talks about the message of the
Episode although it's kind of a downer ending for him. Just like the unity episode was a really downer ending
Number 8 jerry talks himself into making the app because he's a total idiot
So he goes to talk to glooty inside rick's bedroom, which he's repurposed as some sort of office space now
He's put his caught on the other side of the room and replaced it with the photocopier in the whiteboard no idea
What Rick would need a?
Photocopier for because if he can beam his consciousness into other Rick's bodies then why does he need paper to transmit information?
Really? I think the reason is just part of this big intern joke running through the episode the whole idea that everyone from glue DS
Race is a different level of intern and typically you see interns doing really menial slave-like tasks number seven Rick vs
the intruder so it kind of goes into
Terminator mode after he finds that broken branch and you see him analyzing everything going all Sherlock on it
They revealed that everything in this environment is just like Beth's secret place that he created for her. He'd made this entire planet
There are robotic animals everywhere
He has a special secret underground lair control room
And they said that this was also supposed to feel very different from Rick's normal
Inventions where normally his inventions seemed kind of haphazard like you look at his spaceship
It's very advanced, highly
functional but it's cobbled together and it looks kind of like a piece of junk but because they were using this planet to show a
Completely different side of Rick they wanted this space to look like Ilan must designed it super clean super Zen hyper advanced design
Which but I love the idea that he just Scrolls through all these dumps and spends the rest of the episode carrying around
Tony's dump to deliver to him when he finally tracks him down
But number 6 WTF they make the app and they use summer storyline is mostly a joke about how people give away their lives to
algorithms and apps letting tech companies make their choices for them despite the fact that most of the apps themselves are pretty terrible as
evidenced by all the matches that she was with the other part of the story too is that the alien race uses these apps to
Take over planets
but the reason why they're taking over the planet is just because they want their water which is a bit of a joke on the
1983 V science fiction series where a bunch of aliens from Mars that look kind of humanoid or made themselves look humanoid
Wanted to steal all of Earth's water
So summer and most of the rest of Earth's populations spend the next week with in the episode trying to bone
Everyone that the app tells them thir match for which is also a parody of pretty much every dating app ever
I love the way they kind of ease into the craziness though because he gives this impassioned speech and it actually starts out really nice
But then it just devolves into complete chaos with a couple behind them the wife leaving the husband. Sorry
This isn't working out the husband bailing for another match and just leaving the baby there
Just wondering what's going on the dude at the counter even switches his sexuality on the dime because the app tells him that he's into
dudes now
there are couple Easter eggs in the background for restaurants that are
Apparently pretty gross like this one says toe Fung as in toe fungus and then this other restaurant just says chick belly
Number five glooty takes them to the mothership
So Morty despite being the voice of reason somehow thinks that smashing the computer will destroy the app
Morty is smarter than Jerry, but he's still not that smart himself
They turned it into a big full Morty Jerry adventure just like when they went to Pluto together. It's a similar dynamic
Jerry is an idiot and then Morty spends the rest of the episode trying to talk him down and fix things
You look in the background. You see a couple Easter eggs inside Jerry's office
There's a Titanic poster from the Titanic episode
The Gulf poster is from the meeseeks and destroy'
episode when they tried to teach Jerry how to golf and then the ominous beeping app is
Actually a thing in real life in the real world app store
number four Rick's quest for the rogue dumper they have this joke about a mob boss played by Dan Harmon who's a fly running
Whole business for species that are supposed to be his predators. He's also a dealer as he says many times
He has hundreds of thousands of children. You may have also detected the second big celebrity cameo in the episode
It's Pamela add lawn
doing her Bobby hill voice from king of the hill some of the
Animators on Rick and Morty used to work on king of the hill - so there's a bit of a connection between those two shows
So you kind of have to picture a fly version of Bobby hill buzzing around somewhere
There's another big joke about Rick creating major villains for himself in this fly organization
Like he doesn't kill them after he left so they're going to come after him later
Just like zip Zam floorp is still alive down in the tiny verse they create this whole giant intergalactic conflict
But Rick doesn't care about either of the sides
It's sentient robots versus
Crockett's raised from The Vindicator zepa sewed in in order to get that last piece is implied that Rick destroyed most of the Crocky bot
Army completely turning the tide of the war even though he did not care about either one of the sides
I wasn't sure how far they were going to take this motel scene during the episode where summer tries to sleep with the dude
But it is implied that they definitely did it
So he's probably going to be arrested the day after this episode happens
but you started to see how terrible the app actually is when she starts to hate the dude who starts snoring too loudly so she
Can't sleep until it finds her another match and it just continues on and on each new match winds up being super terrible
They do a bit of a parody of the Graduate or any wedding movie where she rushes to stop her next match from getting married
No, no, no, don't marry that person be with me
It erupts into chaos and a bunch of people start flipping the genders that they're in - summer is now in two women she runs
off with that woman and gets on the plane but finds that she's
Disgusted with her when she takes her shoes off and starts picking through her toes on the airplane
Beth shows up and it completely devolves into the airport battle from Captain America Civil War between the two of them as they fight until
glooty saves the day throwing up a paywall
Turns out all it takes to get people to stop using dangerous apps is to make them pay money for them
But number three Jerry Morty vs
the manag a trans as I said the height in turn was played by Sam Neill they created his character first during the episode and
Then the rest of these other little people around him the whole joke about their race though is that he spends this big villain monologue
Explaining how they've mastered committed relationships the when they don't get their basic water needs his own relationship crumbles with his wife
Which is just the writers saying that no one has truly figured out perfect relationships and everybody is kind of bad at it
number two though, Rick versus the rogue dumper
So you also probably recognize this voice - Jeffrey Wright from Westworld is doing the voice of Tony
He's also going to be the voice of Marvel's watcher and their what-if series. It's going to debut during 2021
So he's all over the place
They kind of have a bonding moment
Over dead wives because Rick's also lost his wife even though it hasn't been confirmed that she's dead. We just know that she's gone
There's still a lot of theories about what happened to Rick's wife
They revealed that Rick is really lonely and doesn't actually want to kill Tony despite leaving the most elaborate middle finger device ever
loved the reveal of the giant Rick mech that he uses to sit on Tony the animators on the episode also said that Dan and
Justin spent a lot of time trying to figure out the mechanics of how Rick's giant mechanical
Butt would work and how they would get Tony into this dream sequence big surprise. Tony's fantasy is all about public dumping and strap-ons
So watch out for that
There's a bit of an easter egg for the matrix when it's revealed that they're all in those fluids sacks and rick has just trapped
A whole bunch of people that he's caught previously trying to use his dumper without his permission
But number one WTF Rick finally decides he's going to let someone close to him and be a friend and then the post-credits scene
So he decides to accept Tony as his friend
But he winds up dying and then after that elaborate sequence on the toilet with the special crown
they kind of end on a downer moment as it seems like Rick is never
Going to let someone get close to him and it's a bit like the end of the unity episode where he feels like he's going
To be alone for the rest of his life
they do drop a bit of a funny Beverly Hills reference talking about Texas tea trying to explain to the woman why she shouldn't eat
Those laxative chocolates and all that chili
They revealed that Beth was also using the dating app secretly and almost ran away to be with Ted Danson
The post-credits scene is also a bit of a funny Jerry tag
Like Jerry's mind blowers Jerry goes for a midnight snack and inside the fridge. We find the butter robot. What is my purpose?
You notice the bully that Morty took out in last week's episode is listed as missing on the back of the milk. Carton
Remember, he was just floating away at the end of that episode and it's revealed that Jerry's fantasy is being a simple water delivery
Man, but the water is actually called Mountain sweat, so I wouldn't drink any of that
So let me know in the comments if you spotted any big easter eggs in the episode that I didn't mention in the video. I
Will do an episode 3 trailer video in the next day. So look out for that
Congratulations, Benjamin Abruzzo. You're the giveaway winner from my last big Rick and Morty video
Please email me on the about page of my channel so I can get your details
Everyone click here for my Rick and Morty's Season 4 episode 1 video and click here for my Star Wars
Mandalorian episode 2 video. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!